[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir
permettez-moi de vous demander de fermer
les yeux à l'instant pour imaginer
suivant les indications d'Aurélien je
m'avance en marchant sur une terrasse en
longeant une paroi rocheuse sur ma
gauche
la terrasse s'interrompt
faut maintenant que je me lisse sur un
promontoire qui me semble-t-il s'avance
au dessus du vide alors à Fontainebleau
pas de problème mais là nous sommes
quelque part
au milieu d'une grande voie d'escalade
sur la phase sud de la di Bona la di
Bona c'est une aiguille dans les Alpes
de plusieurs centaines de mètres qui
culminent à 3131 m alors j'ai déjà mon
pied droit sur la dalle oblique j'ai
trouvé de quoi m'accrocher avec la main
droite
j'ai plus qu'à donner une impulsion pour
venir prendre appui dessus sur ce qui me
rappelle le nez du sphinx dans Astérix
et Cléopâtre c'est pas très rassurant
j'y vais évidemment ça tient alors je
continue
en allant dans la direction d'Olivier le
guide haute montagne qui nous attend
plus haut et je laisse la place à
Aurélien
je me présente Franck Morvan 50 ans
kinésithérapeute non voyant depuis une
trentaine d'années
la déficience visuelle je l'ai toujours
vécu mais je voyais suffisamment jusque
vers 14 ans pour suivre à une scolarité
standard ensuite ça a été une lente
dégradation avec adaptation par étape
pour arriver à une quasi cécité vers 22
ans
des sports j'en ai toujours pratiqué
très variés plutôt de plein air et sans
performer outre mesure avirons kayak
tandem un peu course à pied plutôt sur
route et puis escalade depuis quelques
années
la montagne en fait je l'ai évité très
longtemps soigneusement évités à cause
de la cécité mais la randonnée pédestre
le chemin de Compostelle avec ses
chemins parfois un peu délicats la
pratique de l'escalade et
l'adhésion au club alpin on fait que j'y
suis retourné et c'est pour ça que je me
retrouve en 2019 au milieu de la Divona
alors quand même faut être clair j'ai
une appréciation souvent
fausse en tout cas très approximative de
mon environnement évidemment j'ai du mal
à m'en rendre compte même quand on me le
fait remarquer
mais je vais vous rapporter un incident
qui était sans conséquence mais qui est
parlant
j'arrive en 2019 toujours au refuge Théo
duo dans les alpitaliennes mes
compagnons sont un peu plus loin devant
moi j'ai trouvé un banc je pose mon
casque je me délaisse de mon sac à dos
qui bouscule le banc et le casque dévale
en contrebas impossible pour moi d'aller
le chercher tout seul j'avais pas pensé
que le banc était si près d'une pente
ensuite vous savez il y a un décalage
entre danger réel d'Angers perçu tout le
monde connaît ça bon chez moi évidemment
elle est très il est très flagrant
décalage alors l'été dernier par exemple
avec Olivier toujours le même guide et
Joël un ami passionné de montagne nous
faisions une marge d'approche en
direction d'un refuge à travers les
rochers en fait à chaque pas je
stressais à l'idée de tomber entre deux
rochers alors que on y restait vigilant
et il se sentait parfaitement capable de
m'éviter tout danger et le lendemain
c'était un peu différent sur le glacier
dans le labyrinthe de crevasses moi
j'avançais assez tranquillement
alors que eux cette fois ils stressait à
l'idée d'un faux pas éventuel dans une
crevasse
dans Gérer elle danger perçu à noter que
l'escalade sportive
est moins dangereuse que la simple
randonnée en montagne
l'alpinisme c'est autre chose
l'escalade s'envoient
pour donner une image c'est un peu comme
conduire la nuit partant de brouillard
et on a une vision assez courte
fugitive et très partiel de son
environnement
heureusement il y a un copilote
c'est-à-dire la personne qui va
m'assurer du bas ou
grimper un peu au-dessus ou au-dessous
de moi et qui me donne tout un tas
d'informations pour que nous puissions
avancer c'est une double tâche assez
fatigante parce que c'est relativement
permanent
et c'est là qu'on est quand même dans le
thème de ce soir c'est à dire que pour
moi la haute montagne elle est
inenvisageable inaccessible impensable
si je ne pars pas avec des gens qui me
connaissent que je connais et qui sont
prêts à épauler
ensuite il faut quand même qu'on accepte
qu'il y aura un risque supplémentaire
d'échec
par exemple toujours en 2019
j'étais avec Étienne mon beau-fils et
Marie une amie au Club Alpin on était
tout près du sommet du Brighton dans les
monts en Italie à la limite entre le
glacial rocher mais le rocher était
complètement verglacé c'était un terrain
bien plus délicat que prévu alors
Étienne lui avec des grimpeurs de sa
trempe il y serait allé mais là avec moi
dans la cordée il a jugé plus prudent
contre si aventure pas et nous avons dû
rebrousser chemin
il faut aussi accepter les imperfections
la satisfaction quand je vais là haut
sur des terrains que je ne vais fouler
qu'une seule fois faut pas que je
m'étonne de pas toujours être à la
hauteur donc ici c'est Olivier le guide
qui va me tracter avec l'accord pour
m'aider à franchir à part à paix de
glace là dans la gyrose c'est je me
coince à genoux je mets rafle le genou
parce que j'ai fait un mouvement dans la
précipitation peut-être à cause de la
peur dans la di Bona c'était le ma
déception de pas pouvoir aider davantage
Aurélien à se dépatouiller du paquet de
cordes
ce qui fait que après avoir grimpé au
relais prenait aucune pause puisqu'il
s'occupait tout seul de toutes les
cordes
donc ce risque beauté d'échec ces
imperfections je vais quand même essayer
qu'elle de les repousser et pour ça je
m'entraîne
très en amont plus la montagne est haute
plus faut que je me montrais en amont
vous voyez les difficultés
donc je vais m'entraîner sur le mur
d'escalade à répéter ce que j'appelle
les katas de l'escalade et je vais
m'entraîner aussi tout seul dans les
escaliers à monter et remonter des tas
de marche c'est pas très passionnant
c'est plutôt rébarbatif mais c'est
justement cette monotonie qui permet de
travailler l'endurance
qui va me permettre aussi de mériter la
confiance de mes coéquipiers et aussi
d'accepter l'échec éventuel puisque
j'aurais fait le boulot
ensuite en montagne là-haut plus d'égo
si je veux que la cordée avance
facilement je vais suivre les consignes
le plus possible à la lettre et de
prendre aucune initiative
en parlant d'ego j'ai envie de faire un
aparté
il me semble que nous les grimpeurs avec
la panoplie que nous arborons casque
baudrier toute la quincaillerie de
dégaine et de mousquetons nous avons
tendance à adopter un petit air
supérieur parmi les touristes c'est de
votre côté bling bling
mais fin de la partie revenons à nos
mouflons
je suis venu je suis convaincu je n'y
retourne plus
c'est ce que j'ai pensé l'été dernier
quand on est redescendu Olivier et Joël
du refuge Marguerite
c'est un refuge qui a
4554 mètres d'altitude et on avait 1000
mètres de dénivelé à descendre pour
retourner au refuge où nous allions
pouvoir dormir ça a été très long sur le
glacier j'en pouvais plus
l'appel strudel et le chocolat chaud
était bienvenu mais quand même quand on
voit toute la pression la tension que ça
demande à chaque pas les chutes répétées
quand même
la lenteur que j'impose à mes guides et
le stress que je leur inflige tout ça
sans profiter en plus du paysage on peut
se demander si ça va en vaut la peine et
si c'est pas un peu absurde
bon
en fait je crois que ma posture n'est
pas une imposture je crois que j'ai
vraiment voulu apprécier ce que j'ai
vécu ça me laisse des souvenirs
exceptionnels et c'est des moments de
partage aussi n'oubliezables et je me
mettais entraîné beaucoup pour en
profiter
je crois que c'est plutôt dit prétendre
sans se préparer qui serait absurde
dans mon cas
le double sens du mot déterminé
m'interpelle parce que
sans doute la déficience visuelle
à une grande part dans mon besoin de me
confronter à des difficultés pareil
à noter aussi que pour moi pas de haute
montagne sans moyen financier suffisant
dans mon cas
enfin il faut reconnaître que
c'est sans doute
l'ennui la peur du temps qui passe
et le constat de voir mes capacités
physiques qui saveduisent qui me pousse
progressivement quand même à lutter
contre ma force inertie assez naturelle
et la procrastination mais ces vérités
bravache sont assez épuisantes
mais plutôt que de coasser assis au bord
de la barre vraiment je préfère bouger
alors l'alpiniste Gaston Rébuffat disait
en substance je veux aller là où mes
yeux se sont déjà posés
pour ma part c'est plutôt les mots les
noms qui me font rêver des noms entendus
ou lui entendu lors de conversation avec
les grimpeurs je pense à la dent d'orlue
dans les Pyrénées à la dent de la
rancune dans le Massif central où j'ai
pu aller à la di Bona à la Meije au
sanctuaire de elle froide ou au Grand
Paradis en Italie ou méconnu cassebecq
en Géorgie lu avec Frison Roche Herzog
ou licht tech
alors je rêve toujours de repartir
quelque part je rêve depuis très
longtemps du CERVA je rêve aussi du
Kazbek je ne suis pas sûr de pouvoir
aller sur ces sommets donc qui me sont
connus mais le trajet sera la découverte
je peux toujours rêver
en conclusion il faut anticiper faut
savoir où on met les pieds à fortiori
sur un glacier ou une paroi rocheuse
plus le terrain est accidenté et a connu
plus je dois mon tour et de personnes
connues et qui me connaissent bien
et plus le terrain est périlleux plus je
dois me préparer en amont d'un point de
vue physique évidemment mais aussi sur
le plan du savoir autant que faire ce
peu parce que je ne veux pas tout à fait
être un saut dans l'inconnu
et l'écrivain italien
héritel Luca le dit très bien en disant
l'expérience permet de faire confiance à
l'improvisation
ensuite il faut
oser se préparer bien avant qu'un projet
ne soit complètement finalisé quitte à
ce qu'il soit à journée ou annulé c'est
en se préparant très en avance
finalement qu'on entretient la flamme
qu'on rend légitime la réussite et qu'on
accepte l'échec
pour en savoir plus je vous conseille un
très bon petit bouquin de Pascal Brucker
dans l'amitié d'une montagne peut-il
traiter l'élévation ou il écrit il faut
vouloir ce qu'on peut mais on peut
davantage qu'on imagine
toutes ces réflexions la plupart sont
venus sur le trajet quotidien de la
maison au travail du travail à la maison
un trajet facile
reposant ou finalement l'esprit est
libre de penser comme quoi le la marche
routinière a du bon aussi
Claude Nougaro
chantait malicieusement ma voix montre
la voix
ce n'est pas mon cas vous pouvez être
me faire confiance là-dessus faut douter
de ce que je dis en tout cas relever les
contradictions donc cette exposée s'il
vous plaît critiquer le nuancer le merci
et nota bene
j'ai pu réaliser cette exposé grâce à
l'aide de ma famille de mes amis de mes
collègues de mes amis au club alpin et
puis des étudiants de l'ESTACA et des
coachs en prise de parole je vous
remercie tous et tchadjipiti n'a pas eu
son mot à dire ne me dites pas que ça se
voit
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]